I've been covering the Ted Cruz
re-election campaign in Texas Ted Cruz
is one of the most vile disgusting
ideological right-wing members of the
United States Senate right now he's up
for re-election one third of all
senators are up for re-election every
every two years and he actually has a
real challenger on his hands even though
it's Texas even though he's the
incumbent bado
O'Rourke has won the Democratic primary
and is doing very very well I've told
you that O'Rourke in some fundraising
periods in some months has out
fundraised
Ted Cruz which is massive I've told you
that some polls have the race as a
statistical dead heat even though yes as
we get closer to Election Day it's
likely that undecideds will break more
towards Cruz than to the challenger
particularly because Texas has more
registered Republicans than Democrats
but it's not looking good for Ted Cruz
and Republican donors as I told you last
week have started to divest money divert
money I guess would be a better better
way to say it once you donate it you've
donated it but they're diverting money
they would have otherwise donated to
Republicans in other states to help Ted
Cruz win reelection in Texas that's all
great news for better or orc and bad
news for Republicans the latest is now a
sign of total complete desperation Ted
Cruz we learned this morning is now
mailing out donation requests that look
like legal summonses and we're going to
show these to our video and television
audience they send out these brown
envelopes that say on the outside
summons enclosed open immediately the
return address says official county
summons so people get this in the mail
and they think oh I'm being called the
court in some kind of trial something
serious is going on and you open this
envelope and it's not a legal summons
it's a letter from Ted Cruz asking for
money question one is this legal it does
appear to be legal it doesn't seem that
this is illegal as long as somewhere on
the mailing
does identify that this is a piece of
mail paid for by the committee to
re-elect Ted Cruz the campaign to
re-elect had clues and Ted Cruz number
two this is completely deceptive and it
is a sign of complete and total
desperation because if you are so
desperate to get people to send you
money if it's going so poorly that
you're sending pieces of mail implying
that the recipient might be due in court
for some kind of legal proceeding you
are extraordinarily desperate but then
here's the really sick part of all this
some people are getting this and they
are actually thinking they do have to
send a check so like layer one would be
you send something labeled as a legal
summons but people open it and it's
abundantly clear to everybody that oh
it's a letter from Ted Cruz there are
people who are receiving this letter
include including the elderly who see it
and they get confused because the
envelope does look official and they
open it and they think that if they
don't send the check they are breaking
the law in some way again
not illegal as long as it is labeled
somewhere as a piece of campaign mail
but people are actually sending checks
under this pretense I would love it if
someone sent Ted Cruz an envelope which
was labeled campaign donation but was
actually illegal summons although I
don't know that we're gonna be seeing
that any time soon not Ted Cruz's first
time doing this back in 2016 you might
remember Ted Cruz ran for president and
he would send out donation solicitations
that would say voting violation in huge
red font and we know why Ted Cruz is
desperate we know why he was desperate
back in 2016 because he was losing and
we know why he's desperate now because
Beto O'Rourke has matched him almost
dollar for dollar right around 23
million dollars in total fundraising the
notable difference being that Ted Cruz
has raised about twenty three million
dollars accepting money from PACs and
corporations
whereas Beto O'Rourke has raised almost
the exact same amount of money without
accepting money from
and corporations the best possible
reaction to this news about the
deception from Ted Cruz is that a lot of
people hear about it and decide to throw
25 bucks to Beto or Roarke this is a key
race if you have races local to you that
you can work on by all means work on
them but if you are in what is truly a
safe district if you have no interesting
election happening where you live
consider phone banking for better or
work consider a financial contribution
to better or Roarke because if we could
knock out what is arguably who the guy
who is arguably one of the most extreme
right-wingers in the Senate and replace
them with and understandably admittedly
somewhat moderate Democrat it would be a
massive massive blow to the Republican
Party please make sure to follow the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show behind the scenes pictures
including by the way there's a really
great picture on the david pakman show
instagram at david pakman show right now
of the show it's a shot from behind the
camera showing my entire remote setup
while I've been working on this project
in Paris France which by the way ends
this week and I'll be back in the studio
at the end of the week we've got a
behind-the-scenes picture posted and if
you're following a David Pakman show you
might as well follow at David Pakman my
personal account pictures from the trip
and much more we will take a break next
we will deal with Flat Earth conspiracy
theories I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a
really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important in
from
the themes the insights from each book
and they distill it into a 15-minute
audiobook that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blink Asst our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is calm slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa ke ma n